just hours before flying off to palm
beach florida and skipping the
inauguration
donald trump issued his final list of
pardons
and he is not on the list and his
children are not on the list and we will
talk a little bit about why
momentarily a lot of speculation about
that
but the list does include a variety of
individuals 143 pardons maybe most
prominently steve bannon
former white house chief strategist and
close adviser to donald trump
pardoned now the insane there's nothing
more trumpy than the following
steve bannon was arrested for felony
fraud
for defrauding build the wall donors
these were pro-trump donors who wanted
to build the wall
they donated to this hey give us money
and we'll build it
and it was a total scam trump pardoned
the guy who scammed trump's
own supporters and if you needed any
more proof
that trump never cared about his
supporters beyond how they were useful
to him politically
it is the pardon of steve bannon how
many times does trump need to betray
his own supporters before they realize
trump never cared about them to begin
with
also uh pardoned eliot broidy former
republican finance chair
kwame kilpatrick former democratic mayor
of detroit
randy duke cunningham a former
republican congressman rick renzi former
republican congressman robin hayes
former republican congressman two
rappers lil
wayne and kodak black uh
notably missing from the list are
pardons for his family and
pardons for himself and this apparently
was the culmination of a pretty dramatic
couple of days where on saturday evening
this is a report
from cnn donald trump
was warned he had a long meeting with
his advisors on saturday night
and at that point he still was leaning
towards pardoning in advance
his children his son-in-law maybe rudy
giuliani and possibly even himself
and he was told don't do it he was told
if you pardon them
and even yourself you will be placing
yourself
in a legally perilous position it will
convey the appearance of guilt it will
potentially make you
more vulnerable to reprisals and indeed
donald trump acquiesced to that
and decided not to pardon his children
and not to pardon himself some of these
warnings came from white house counsel
pat chipoloni as well as another
attorney
eric hirschman who was involved in
defending trump in his first impeachment
trial and they all said to trump do not
pardon yourself
do not pardon your family do not pardon
any anybody in a prospective manner
unless you will list specific crimes
and that was the concern a blanket
preemptive pardon
had trump said well i pardon ivanka in
advance
for campaign finance crimes as an
example
this lawyer said that would be better
but it also is pointing a finger at
specific crimes you believe
maybe they would be charged with and in
the end trump deciding i'm not going to
pardon
any of them and even after saturday
trump kept bringing this up even after
people around trump thought
it's done he's not going to pardon his
kids or himself
trump kept bringing it up bringing it up
bringing it up and the final
meeting reportedly where trump finally
was convinced okay i'm not going to do
it
took place on a saturday evening and
it's interesting as a general thing
because trump has often ignored advice
given
advice given to him in fact trump
ignoring advice given to him is
responsible for much of the trouble
that he got into during his presidency
and uh there's a reason why defense
attorneys
say even if you think you had nothing to
do with the crime it's better not to
answer questions to law enforcement
just call a lawyer and say you don't
want to say anything
there's a reason why that's the case and
much of donald trump's trouble if we
look back at his
beleaguered for years much of that
trouble caused by trump choosing to
speak rather than not by trump trump
choosing to act
rather than doing nothing and just
waiting for things to happen without his
involvement
and i don't know if there's a lesson
here i mean the real lesson should be
how on earth how how can we prevent
75 million people from being bamboozled
by this guy and thinking it's a good
idea to elect him that's really the
lesson that hopefully we would learn and
and and somehow prevent in the future i
don't know if that's the case i don't
know if that has been learned
but the pardon list the final pardon
list is out
so this is the end of the trump
era and the beginning of the biden era
tomorrow we will have the timing of
today made it difficult to have
inauguration coverage today on the show
we'll be covering it live and maybe
you're with us right now maybe you
watched it earlier with us
tomorrow we will have coverage of the
biden inaugural the initial speech
scheduled to have a press briefing
already
from trump's uh biden's incoming press
secretary jen sackey tonight
and then joe biden already scheduled
today to sign a bunch of executive
orders which you can be sure
we will be uh looking at tomorrow and
seeing if joe biden sticks to his
promises
so quick break let me know your thoughts
about what's go
excuse me what's going on on twitter
where you can find me at deepakman
and then a bunch of final stories to tie
up some loose ends coming up here
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
cal tech scientists with only one
mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen cinnamon and
pomegranate they also have lozenges
which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer
i'm required to give these products
contain
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical